can can i interrupt for one second yes
gen
4 it didn't give me a choice of
where but it um
i'm making sure that it's recording to
the cloud we should be all set
all right thank you okay all right you
might want to stop your recording
because yeah it might have been on the
you know why because i failed to make
you a co-host but we're going to change
that right now
okay there we go
okay so so good you're doing this jenny
i'm really glad that uh
we have someone second second set of
eyes
great job are we all set
jen we are yes i
tried to stop mine but
does that mean that uh janine
that janine gets in a special license
plate
as chair of the house regular license
plan
declared by the government as a result
of the clover 19 epidemic
and in accordance with the house rule 67
and the governor's emergency order
number 12
pursuant to executive order 2020-04
this public body is authorized to meet
electronically
this is a session relative to revenues
please note there is no physical
location for members of the public to
observe and listen contemporariously to
this meeting
however in accordance with the emergency
order i am confirming that
all members of the committee and select
legislative staff have the ability to
communicate contemporariously
during this meeting through the zoom
electronic meeting platform
and the public has accessed the
contemporaries of listen
and if necessary participate in this
meeting by the zoom platform
or by telephone all necessary access
information has been
made available on the house calendar and
through the electronic calendar on the
general court website
the notice for this meeting complies
with the health schools rsa
91a anyone who has a problem accessing
the meetings
call 271 3600
or email hcs live.state.nh.edu
in the event the public is unable to
access the meeting
the meeting will be adjourned and
rescheduled
i want to introduce the staff their
meeting assisting
us jennifer four committee researcher
please note that all votes that are
taken during this meeting should be done
by roll call vote
let's start the meeting by taking a roll
call attendance
when each member states their presence
please also state
whether there is anyone in the room with
you during this meeting which is
required under the right to know law
representative bernstein you've
commenced with the role
thank you thank you thank you mr
chairman buenas diaz amigos
let's begin wrong call
april the 29th 2021 1003 a.m we'll begin
roll call with representative
abrami yes i'm here at my home in
stratham
i'm alone thank you representative mary
griffin
representative owery holm
hudson wife is in the house
thank you representative ober erin
hudson with the six cats
good morning representative doucette
good morning here in
the clerk is representative bershke and
i'm in nottingham new hampshire
in my home office by myself
representative robert elliott
uh here in salem at my daughter's house
and i'm very warm right now
because i've got the fireplace on
don't tell her that alan as long as
you're comfortable
representative to niggian good morning
uh home alone in my office in salem new
hampshire
good morning representative nunes
representative baxter
i believe representative baxter is still
in florida filming an episode of reps
gone wild or something like
that representative skillsbury
good morning home alone in charlestown
representative tudor good morning uh
home in northwood wife and kids are in
the house good morning representative
homie
on good morning home blown in lebanon
representative ames yes i'm here in
jeffrey
in my home office alone
representative southward here in dover
alone
good morning representative malloy here
in greenland
alone representative thomas schamberg
thank you representative bernstein your
voice is just so calming
i'm here in wilmette by myself in my
office thank you
good morning it's always nice to hear
your voice tom representative tucker
i'm alone in randolph
representative gomarlo i am in swansea
and alone representative laughman
representative gorg good morning i am
present and alone
good morning representative hackenfield
good morning
i am president from my office in concord
representative murphy
and our chairman representative norman
major
good morning i'm in my home in palasto
my wife is in the house
mr chair we have 19 members present five
are not here
thank you representative burns
this morning we're fortunate on a short
notice to have
brian rotblog who is employed by the
employment security as an economist
is to talk to us about the
new hampshire economy and how it fits in
with the rest of
the nation we're hoping to have
emily brock
but emily brock responded
and said essentially if i can
jen yeah she did get back to us last
night
with her apologies for not responding
sooner um
but essentially she didn't have any
update yet
um she did indicate that she's expecting
some of the
guidance from treasury to be released on
monday
and that she would pass that along as
soon as she receives it
and if that happens there's a
possibility we may be able to have a
virtual conversation when we meet to
discuss
revenues on wednesday of next week
so if and then after uh
we're through with mr brian
upload we will discuss some other
matters relative to the committee
brian it's always a pleasure to have you
here
it's the floor is yours thank you very
much
mr chairman um again thank you for the
invitation
it was a little bit short notice so i
didn't have time to
um kind of tailor some of my remarks
as much as i would like to the what i
think are the needs
of your committee but i but i did add um
some information i think that is of
interest and i know you folks had some
interest
in the issue of ppp loans so i
have a little bit of information on that
hopefully
maybe we'll shed a little bit of light
but beyond that um the overall message
that i'll be talking about is what's
happening i think in the in the new
hampshire economy and what it's going to
look like over the next couple of years
and in that regard it's a very different
outlook than i think when i spoke to you
in january at a joint
house and senate ways and means
committee at that time i was expecting
it to be a very difficult first half of
of the year
it did certainly start out that way the
first few months but
i think the improvements have
accelerated at a pace that was a little
bit quicker than i had anticipated
and there's a lot of very positive
economic information
that's coming out nationally so with
that it has significantly upgraded my
outlook for the new hampshire economy so
with that rather long introduction
i hope you'll be able to see my screen
and are you seeing the first chart
yes we are all right perfect you know
it's always a
i've i've done so many different
platforms and zoom usually works
but i've done every imaginable um remote
platform
some of them work better than others
this one luckily
it looks like it's going to work out so
before would you be able to email us a
copy of this
sure absolutely i usually i thank you
for reminding me i always say that
usually say that at the beginning
frequently i forget but i will make a
copy of this i'll send it to jennifer
and she can distribute it if that's okay
great thank you sure so um just
because i've got quite a few slides um
if i were to summarize
sort of the outlook this is what i would
say um
and a lot of this i i presented most
recently at a manchester chamber
economic outlook uh presentation i've
updated some of the charts and
added some additional information
because i only had about 20 minutes on
that one this one i guess i got a little
bit longer
so basically what i see
is that for the rest of 2021 and 2022
we're going to see
pretty significant job gains and gdp
growth is going to really accelerate
and our unemployment will fall quickly
we had really good
job numbers nationally in
march i think the april numbers will
show that
as well so we're going to see um
reemployment
kicking kicking up pretty rapidly
yep would you take questions as you're
going along
oh sure sure it'll be it will be hard
for me to
because i the way the screen is um
so you're gonna have to just interrupt
me
um if you want um to because i
you know i talk a lot and i talk fast so
whoever wants to ask a question is i
won't be able to see them
um so if you can recognize them that
would be great
um so it's not just a hospitality
industry you know they suffered
in retail but at least in new hampshire
and nationally in new hampshire 80
percent of the industries
in the last monthly report had added
jobs so it's pretty the gains in the
re-employment gains are
really broad-based and that's an
excellent sign we expected that
that hospitality industry would pick up
as the weather improved
as as vaccines rates increased
but it's really almost across the board
um and particularly in some of the
industries that have been hardest hit
manufacturing nationally is booming um
new hampshire i believe won't be very
far behind there's a couple of
industries that i think are going to
really do well the computer and
electronics and that's
led just one example ba systems
they have a big portion of the
f-35 fighter jet
and they make a large percentage of the
components in that airplane
and it was just a new contract um issued
for that so
i expect that they'll you know they'll
benefit from that as will some other
aerospace related manufacturing and our
medical manufacturing
is you know you've seen it in that in
some of the headlines and some of the
newspaper reports
companies that have announced expansions
or locations in new hampshire and
you know i've i've prepared a couple of
labor market analysis for those
companies so
um those are just two examples of i
think where
um the manufacturing sector is is really
even during the pandemic was doing
pretty well
but um are really poised to lead the
growth
this la this next one the favorable
demographics i know there was a report
yesterday
about you know the slow population
growth and
not unexpected um over the last
uh decade it's been slower
but our demographics and this is one of
the ironies or one of the
i hate to say there's any advantage to
the pandemic but as i will show you
it has made new hampshire relatively
more attractive
i don't know there was a story in the
new york times i think about
areas rural areas in the country that
were attracting
the most residents from other states and
lebanon new hampshire happen to be one
of them
but throughout new hampshire we're
seeing an increase in interest and i'll
talk a little bit more about that and
that's been our biggest challenge
really is demographics and with the
increased migration that i expect
it will help us address some of those um
this is related
we have the fourth highest home
appreciation in the nation now that's a
a benefit if you own a home it's a
negative and your wealth
it's a negative if you're looking to buy
and we do have housing cost issues um
but you know again it speaks to the
attractiveness of the state and one of
those
you know i have to be honest and i'm not
a not an overtly political person but
you know the things that i see and the
things that i hear
about why people are interested is
obviously a great state with a lot of
opportunities but it also does offer an
advantage in terms of the tax burden
which does help attract and retain
working-age residents
um again not a political person so
whether you like this
you know american rescue plan or not um
it will provide stimulus to the to the
economy
those stimulus impacts really didn't
show up much
in the march employment economic numbers
but we're going to start seeing it
beginning this month when you know early
next month when the april numbers
show up and again the supporting
environment
some sort of infrastructure plan and i'm
not
commenting on whether you know this one
that's proposed by
by the administration is necessarily the
best or the worst
but there's going to be some sort of
increase in
in infrastructure investment it's needed
because
we've under-invested and that will
provide additional boost to economic
activity
both in the short term and longer term
because i think um depending on how that
money is spent
it can help increase productivity and
lower business costs so
that's kind of the overall um generic
outlook or the the you know to set the
stage and i'll get into some
more specifics now um what i thought i'd
do
is kind of take it take us a little bit
through where
we're coming from this is employment
in new hampshire non-farm
total employment in new hampshire prior
to the pandemic and you see it was
increasing pretty steadily during the
last recession it dropped
a little bit of a drop at the very end
there
i had forecast prior to the pandemic
that new hampshire would see
employment growth of about just under
one percent in 2020 and 1.2
in 2021 well that sort of
went out the window with the pandemic
and this is what happened
you see that red line which is just a
dramatic
drop in employment you know over a
hundred thousand
uh people um were unemployed
either collecting unemployment benefits
or or lost jobs
and we bounced back pretty significantly
it was sort of looking like a
more of a v-shaped recovery but then
that second wave of the pandemic hit
and you saw see a drop there in the that
began in the fall of 2020
and we've recovered again from that and
and job growth is picking up and
a little bit later i'll show you what my
forecast is and how it relates to that
but the bottom line is we still have a
ways to go yes
i'm sorry return to elliot
yeah maybe represent elliott
bob i think you're muted you're muted
bob
there you go go ahead yeah brian i want
to go back to
your first point which ties into this
one what what
is the present uh unemployment rate
in new hampshire yeah now i actually
have a chart on that
and i wanted to explain a little bit
about it and i
i'm jumping ahead here um it is three
percent
officially now the official unemployment
rate
um only from my perspective doesn't
really
accurately reflect where we are
i'll tell you vermont has the lowest
unemployment rate
or one of the lowest unemployment 2.9
percent
i don't believe vermont's economy is a
2.9 percent on unemployment rate economy
we are at three percent but that only
includes about
half the people who are collecting
unemployment benefits
the bureau of labor statistics has
calculated unemployment rates based on
people who lost their job either
temporarily
from for a layoff or permanently those
are the people who are and
who want work so those are the people
who are officially counted as
unemployment
during the pandemic what happened as
was a couple of federal programs were
created
pandemic unemployment assistance which
allowed people
who couldn't work for various reasons
related to the pandemic either they had
health issues
child care issues etc a number of issues
to they were allowed to collect
unemployment benefits
so that's different than the historical
way the bureau
counts unemployment so from the bureau
of labor statistics perspective they
don't want to change the definition
for the official unemployment rate just
because of the pandemic which we thought
was going to be a few months
so they continue to calculate their rate
only using people who meet the original
definition of unemployment they do not
count in
the people who are able to collect the
benefits because their hours were cut
because they were self-employed
because they had child care issues or
they had health issues
so when you factor those people into the
rate
our rate is almost double it's about six
percent
um and that's true of most states so
um you know it's very hard for me to say
new hampshire has a three percent
unemployment rate
when i know there's still over 30 000
people collecting
unemployment benefits thanks for the
explanation
brian very good okay
all right so this is again where we
where we are and we've got a long you
know we've got a ways to go to get back
all of the jobs you know we're starting
i think for the remainder of the year
we may have a month where it's not so
great but i think we're gonna
we're gonna you know add there's a i
don't know of a business that isn't
looking to hire people
so we're gonna add jobs big part will be
getting people
back into the labor force but it's going
to take a while it'll be 2022 before
you know probably mid late 2022 before
we even get back to where we were
pre-pandemic
and this chart just shows what's
happened to the labor force
a lot of people have stepped out of
labor force um
you know because of the pandemic some
people
had health issues i'll tell you there
was a large
a fairly large segment of across the
country uh of um you know
older workers who decided well uh this
may be the time to start collecting
social security
um there was a big increase in social
security applications for social
security benefits i don't have that data
specifically to new hampshire
so people at the older end of the
of their working lives stepped out we
had a lot of
women in particular who stepped out of
the labor force
because they tend to be primary
caregivers
so when schools were closed and
there were fewer options for child care
or child supervision
a lot of women stepped out of labor
force so getting people back
into the labor force is going to be
really really critical
for my forecast to work and for us to
add the jobs that i think
potentially we could add we we are
seeing
a strong demand for labor um but
uh it's not being as filled as quickly
and some of that can be helped by
schools being back in in you know
in-person learning child care will be a
big part of it getting more child care
uh
facilities opened and at full staff a
lot of pieces to get people back into
the labor force vaccine
is going to help you have a question uh
representative sellsworth sure thank you
it's exactly what you're talking about
i live in the seacoast and as each week
goes by
employers getting more and more
desperate they're even wondering to what
extent they can
open and i'm not sure there actually is
going to be a solution for this summer
um it just seems like the list of jobs
you know
and the lack of housing really are not
something that can be solved quickly
yeah the the the there's plenty of jobs
out there um you know there are
i mean the lack of workers i misspoke
yeah the lack of workers
well you know here's the thing is that
we have
we still have 30 000 people collecting
unemployment benefits and i know i was
quoted i live in the seacoast
also representative southworth and you
know i was quoted in the
in the dover the fosters
related to the hospitality industry a
lot of restaurants have openings
you know in dover this past weekend i
wanted to do takeout and i found three
restaurants that i
wanted to get take out from are no
longer doing takeout because
they're concentrating they don't have
the staff and they're concentrating
on the in-person dining so um but yep
we have 3 800 people collecting
unemployment benefits
in that industry so um you know we we're
starting
up the work search requirement again
which had been suspended
you know people and rightly so during
the pandemic it was
very difficult for people to go out and
search for work
businesses were open they weren't you
know in they didn't
allow in-person interview whatever so
that was suspended but now
uh beginning in may may 23rd individuals
who are collecting unemployment benefits
are going to have to certify that they
have
actually you know looked for work and if
they were offered
enough uh a position um you know they're
expected
to to take it if it's an equivalent
position so
um i think that will help um i think i'm
not starting
yep i'm sorry when is that starting
uh may 23rd okay
yeah and that was um at the at the
governor's
um uh i think executive order
um you know the i think in most states
or a lot of states that suspended their
work requirements as well
so we weren't unusual in that
representative has a question
sure yeah thank you for taking my
question
um i understand how that would work with
something like
the food service or hospitality or even
manufacturing
where some a person with a skill could
go out and do it
but what about the individuals that are
relying
upon government to take place for
example
in new hampshire the courts are closed
those people that work for the court um
lawyer
well yeah two degree lawyers
their uh private secretaries are per or
company secretaries
they can't just go out and find work on
their own
how's it going how are you going to be
able to look for work
if your work has been closed by the
government
yeah i i i mean i'm not sure that we've
got
uh governments uh you know i'm not sure
how what is closed anymore
um from my perspective pretty much all
of the
you know there there aren't any
restrictions on
on um i you know there are there are
every almost everything is going to be
open very soon courts are getting back
into um and i only know this because i
happen to know somebody who works
in the in the judicial system um they're
going to be going back to having trials
etc
they've been doing work um
you know if they haven't been having
in-person trials they've been doing work
there aren't in the private sector i'm
not sure there
are any restrictions anymore other than
voluntary
um if i could interrupt in the banking
um you're limited to the number of
people you can have in the lobby
you're limited uh by uh dictate
as to uh foreclosure processes
or or renewing or
developing your your banking trade by
dictate
uh where does that leave uh a chunk of
people
well actually in the fi in the finance
industry they we've added jobs so i
don't think that's a much of a
you know more of that's been online um
so
you know when i look at the numbers in
terms of of jobs and people filing for
unemployment there really isn't
that it doesn't seem to be an issue in
that particular industry
i don't mean to suggest that if you
can't go into the lobby
that doesn't create inconvenience for
some people but just
in looking at the data um you know
the the finance industry has
not really seen a shrinkage there are
some individual businesses that have
chosen to you know to close branches but
from my perspective that has a lot more
to do with what you know is happening in
the uh
you know in the profitability of those
particular
uh locations and it does with any
particular restrictions but
um you know that's not representative
already that's really not my
um you know those decisions aren't mine
they're not my
organizations um and you know when you
the restriction i have nothing to do
with the restrictions
my organization doesn't have anything to
do with the restrictions on what
businesses can do i'm just saying from
my perspective
i thought most of what restrictions on
private sector activity had been removed
or
were very close to being removed by the
the reopening commission um i may be
wrong on that but i thought
pretty much all of it had had opened up
again
um so i may be wrong on that but um
you know i i can't debate whether it was
a good move or not it wasn't
our my decision um
you know whether whether you believe
we're
we're we have more restrictions or not i
you know i can't
i really can't speak to that although i
just spent five minutes speaking to it
um just to give you an idea of the
continued claims for unemployment this
is
just where you know how we compare
continued claims are people who on a
week to week basis
file for unemployment and we saw a
pretty significant drop early on
you know through the summer it picked up
again again
um you know kind of with the second wave
and then the winter time
it started to fall again but we still
have
a ways to go we still have over 30 000
individuals who are collecting
unemployment benefits
about uh about half of them
in what is called the regular
unemployment insurance program which
you know the people who are laid off in
or lost their jobs
in sort of what we i hate to say the
traditional way
the other half is through the new
programs that were started the pandemic
unemployment assistance which allows
people to
you know who have been affected by the
pandemic
you know to collect benefits and that
includes self-employed gig workers
people who have child care or health
issues
so we're we're making progress um i
think
we'll see some acceleration in that
progress
um one of the ironies and you know
we've talked about this a little bit is
the number of job openings during 2020
was actually higher
than the number of job openings or
postings in 2019
you know there's a lot of reasons for
that part of that is is that the labor
force shrunk so
people stepped out of the labor force
for various reasons
um and when it did that didn't
mean necessarily that the business
didn't have a need for
for a worker so a lot of a lot of
openings went unfulfilled
um in 2000 2020
we're seeing again even a greater pickup
in the number of job postings and
interestingly
you know some different categories
there's going to be some
reallocation of labor you know we're
going to see fewer retail
jobs we're going to see more
transportation and warehousing jobs
some of that was happening prior to the
pandemic as you know brick and mortar
retailing
was was suffering a bit
or more than a little bit because of
online retailing that accelerated during
the pandemic
we'll probably see fewer hospitality
restaurant
workers there sadly there's going to be
some that
restaurants that will not survive and
what we're seeing is more
remote listings one of my projects is to
try and get a better handle on the
number of remote job listings
the pandemic has increased remote
working it means
that people can get jobs far away from
where they live
that's both a benefit and a curse to new
hampshire and i'll
talk a little bit more about it but i
did a presentation to
to some tech industries a few weeks ago
and i looked at
information technology workers and the
number three
employer looking to hire workers
in new hampshire was facebook facebook
has no
no operation in new hampshire so we're
going to see a lot more
companies and we're seeing it looking to
grab our talent
we will get the people um what we've got
to do is
translate the people who are moving here
into into uh
people who are also working here um
i just quickly you know these are some
of the industries that have
added workers um and i look at the march
to 2021 time period the change march
2020 the data was collected just before
things shut down so it's a pretty good
indicator
and what you see is there was a lot of
industries that have added workers
over the year what isn't shown here is
the ones that lost and the ones that
lost
personal services you know the kinds of
high contact
interactions that require interactions
interpersonal interactions
so retailing loss you know hospitality
restaurants loss not
not the limited services restaurants
which i put up here
those are like the fast food and the
takeout
through the drive-thru uh made it you
know
and one of the few alternatives during
the peak of the pandemic where you could
you know you could
purchase um food away from home so a lot
of
a lot of industries did add um
unfortunately
there were several industries that lost
big
numbers um and hospitality is is the one
that really jumps out
um also
surprisingly healthcare you know
hospitals
and other health care providers stopped
providing
discretionary or non-emergency services
so we saw a big decline in in
employment in health care and that's
picked up um since but still is
is down a little bit
this is uh just i just wanted to point
this out because it
it you know it's both good and bad um it
shows
um and this is data that's not survey
data it's actually census
of our employers which occurs on a
quarterly basis
and we're just about finished with the
fourth quarter but
third quarter was a peak you know peak
of the pandemic and it shows
um what the wages
of industries that lost jobs and this is
a weighted average so it takes the
number of people who lost jobs in those
industries
versus the ones that gained and what
their
wages are the average weighted average
and what it shows is that the jobs that
were lost were lower paying and that's
you know i don't mean to suggest that
those
it's you know that makes it any better
because that's
especially uh problematic because
individuals who are lower wage tend to
be lower skill
and have fewer opportunities to find
other
employment or re-employment but the
industries that added jobs
tended to be you know well-paying
industries
we see a lot of professional services a
lot of technology
related employment saw pretty
significant gains and i just
you know take a look at i highlighted a
few of these
that are well paying industries
and the percentage increase in
employment over that same time period
so you know scientific research and
development services isn't a
big employer in the state but it's
growing and it grew during the pandemic
financial investment
computers you know a lot of well-paying
industries
and what's characteristic of these
they can make people could work from
home and that's the real difference
you know those lower wage jobs that were
lost
most of them almost all of them were in
industries that required a high degree
of personal contact
if it was personal services you know you
think hair dressers
nail salons and you know all kinds of
activities like that or retail
or hospitality high person contact these
jobs
that were added allowed businesses to
continue the operation because a lot of
people could work from home
i one of the things that i've done and a
lot of economists have done during the
pandemic is look to private sector
data sources um you know the bureau of
labor statistics provides a lot of my
organizations funding because we
partner with them to collect employment
and unemployment data and labor force
data
but one of the challenges is that data
is collected and reported with a pretty
significant lag at least
you know six months or six weeks beyond
when it was collected so
i've really struggled during the
pandemic and a lot of people have to try
and get more timely information and the
private sector has offered
a lot of different a lot of sources have
stepped up
and this is one of them and it's a
company called wompley that
provides transactional services
for small businesses and they define
businesses a business as being closed
as one that didn't have a financial
transaction a credit card transaction
um over a three-day period so if it goes
three days without a transaction it's
considered close
so it may open up again later but they
do
report this data and they this chart
shows
compared to the pre-pandemic number of
businesses that were closed
what percentage are considered closed
throughout the pandemic and what you see
is
during the worst of it in april when
things were really shut down and
many many businesses were not allowed to
operate many industries
almost half of the small businesses
didn't have a financial transaction over
three weeks
now that has improved but we're still at
about
15 to 20 percent um
if you average it out of small
businesses that
would be considered remain closed and
they tend to be the smallest of
of small businesses so that's you know
that's a problem
and i said a long time ago early on in
this
pandemic that i expected that probably
as many as 15 percent of the
small businesses might not survive
um the the the longer it goes and
we know it's gone very long and
unfortunately there's some
there's some geographic aspects to this
too i'm you know
i think this plays into some of the the
you know the rural
more urban discrepancies because
just you know one example if a
restaurant closes in downtown portsmouth
there will be another restaurant to open
up there in not too long
because that place gets visitors all the
time
but you know if a restaurant closes in a
community in the north country
doesn't have the same demographics
doesn't get the same visitors
it may not be replaced so you know i
fear that there could be some
um you know some exacerbation of the
of the rural urban north south uh
um you know problems as a result of the
pandemic
ryan we have a question from
representative on that
sure i'm brian
could you tell us what how you define a
small business
the feds say 500 workers and that's all
of new hampshire
it's pretty much yeah it's it's all of
but you know but
uh uh probably a few dozen in new
hampshire
um yeah i you know i have a very hard
time with the 500
definition when i think of a small
business i think of 50 and under
you know something like that um along
that lines and
and you know you know we just we just
it just doesn't fit our um
you know it doesn't fit our economy and
it doesn't fit many states economy
uh to suggest you know it to put a
business of 500 on the same plane as
kind of a local retailer you know small
or a restaurant just
to me doesn't make a lot of sense i i'm
not sure
i'm not sure how that came about my
guess is you know
if you're the small business
administration that gives you a much
larger clientele
and a much larger you know number of
businesses
which you can do you know uh do business
with
but it to me it doesn't make a lot of
sense um i
i've looked at in the past that how they
came up with that
i can't i can't figure out what the
rationale is it's not what most people
think of as a small business
brian representative tucker has a
question too yeah
i just want to make sure that
it's three days that womp yeah just
yeah and the second thing i
i throw out is the
50 is where the family and medical
leave kicks in
so that may be a small business
number that's easier to track because
right they have to conform and so there
should be statistics
which i think would be more useful in
new hampshire
right oh yes no doubt about it i mean
you know i don't have enough the top of
my head but we do know how many
businesses with employees that we have
at those different break points and i do
you know i do know
up to 49 i don't have it off the top of
my head but i do know how many
businesses we have
in new hampshire at that number and how
many people they employ
you know we do keep that kind of data so
where where would i be able to find that
if i wanted a good question
i would love to well that's another
thing on my agenda we have
a lot of good information we present it
horribly on our website
so i can't even i can't off the top of
my head
and maybe it's because i haven't been
here long enough but i will get you that
information i think that it's very very
useful for ways and means
yeah no doubt about it we have a
really a lot of good information it's
just not all that accessible and that's
not
you know unique to to new hampshire
government
it's you know i'm i the worst
from my perspective website i ever go to
is the census bureau
very hard to find easily information
there
um so we've got to do a better job and
we are actually in the process
of doing that we've done some good
things with in my operation
granite stats which is a very user
friendly with an easy interface
that allows you to get information
employment income
on at the community level the county
level the regional planning level
um really intuitive interface so that's
that was kind of the first step
and uh if you go to our our uh
you know the elmi portion of the new
hampshire employment security website
you can
poke around with that but i think that's
a a really good beginning
oh i'll try it thank you very much yeah
um so oh i should go back
i just this is just a chart it's another
private sector source home base
um they do um you know payroll an hour
uh you know scheduling and so they do
the same sort of thing compared to prior
you know pre-pandemic how many you know
what percentage
of um of of businesses or the median
hours
how does it compare to pre-pandemic
levels in new hampshire we see about a
17. so it's very pretty consistent with
that whole
um you know 15 to 20 percent of small
businesses that are closed it's
the one thing it does show is that and i
added is that
new hampshire is a little bit better off
than our you know our
our neighbors and i think that's the
appropriate comparison because we all
kind of suffered
the same you know um uh pandemic effects
you know we all had you know
kind of similar regulations and we
all had sort of similar outbreaks etc
so it's appropriate you could find you
know
some states out west that are much
better but they didn't have the same
kind of
impact the pandemic didn't have the same
kind of impact
um so you know so
we've got closures and we've got um
hours cut back but what
i look at you know i'm always trying to
find something positive here
is that um the number of
uh new business formations and this data
is from the irs so it's basically
businesses
that have filed for employer
identification numbers
and the census bureau takes that
information
and they divide it up into different
categories so you can get
you know a sole proprietor wanting to do
that you can get
different kinds of businesses but what
they do is they
divide it up into a couple of different
categories that i think are
are important and one of them is a high
propensity to hire and that's based on
some statistical work that
finds that the when um an organization
seeks a an employer id number
in that particular industry it's very
likely that that will turn
into an organization that hires
employees
they also have one where not only
have they a high propensity to hire but
they've
actually gotten to the process where
they come to
an employment security agency and have
started a
you know an account to do to pay to do
payroll taxes that's a smaller number
and it happens a little bit later so
there's a lag there so i
focus in on this high propensity to hire
and what you see is there obviously was
a drop during you know kind of the peak
of the pandemic
but it has picked up and so we're seeing
some creativity
um you know there are new opportunities
created in the new hampshire economy so
while we have lost
um uh and we will lose many small
businesses
there are a number of opportunities that
have been created
um and i think you know we'll see kind
of a burst of
uh you know new activity as a result and
it
you know doesn't happen immediately but
definitely if you
trend that out some of that upswing is
simply the record
you know recovering the numbers but it
continues and i haven't
you know looked at the most this data
comes out on a weekly basis some of the
best data
you know high frequency timely data that
that i can get in terms of what's
happening with
you know interest in starting new
businesses in new hampshire
so that's one of the you know one of the
good good aspects
oh oh i don't know why is that i think
that's a repeat
i've done that one okay i did want to i
did um
i did want to this is kind of out of
place i didn't want to skip around but i
mentioned that whole
notion of the official unemployment rate
versus
what i calculate and bureau of labor
statistics
probably doesn't like the fact that
people like me
calculate a different unemployment rate
so i can't call it um
the same thing otherwise they would take
away my birthday and my
funding but this is you know
i did this for every state but take a
look at all of the people who are
collecting benefits
as a percentage of the pre-pandemic
labor force to come up with what i call
the kova 19 affected unemployment rate
to me that's a better measure of how our
labor market
has been affected by the pandemic and
where we are right now
so while new hampshire has an official
rate of 3.0
and that's here i don't know if that
shows up
my marker here um
you know i calculate and i haven't done
it for the most
recent week um but is about 5.6
and vermont has a ridiculous 2.9
unemployment rate not because they've
had they they had a lot of jobs but
because their labor force is shrinking
um they're what i calculate is their
real unemployment rate if everybody
who's collecting unemployment benefits
we're counting
is over 10 percent the other end you see
some
states that actually benefit from the
covet 19 affected unemployment those are
states that tend not to have a lot of
people collecting the pua
and the puc benefits and because the
coveted rate that i calculate uses
pre-pandemic labor force
they have more people
in the labor force not as many people
collecting on benefits
and as a result their their rate
actually drops that's a little bit of an
esoteric
um piece of data but i i
really have a hard time suggesting that
we're at a three percent
unemployment i know it makes us feel
very good
um but you know we know there's too many
people unemployed to suggest that we're
almost back to where we were prior to
the pandemic we have we have a ways to
go we're
we're making some significant
improvement but we have a ways to go
another private sector source of data
that i look at
is moody's analytics and cnn
put together what they call the back to
normal index and it uses
seven or eight state level economic
variables pieces of data along with
about
16 to 20 national
economic variables and it calculates
how close to pre-pandemic
economic activity each state and the
nation
is it doesn't mean that
new hampshire's economy was exactly
or very close to the u.s economy what it
means is that we're
right now just about 11
below where we were prior to the
pandemic the u.s economy is about 13
below and the new hampshire the
massachusetts economy
is about 19 below what it was performing
at prior
to the pandemic so again it shows that
we made
improvement we were making really rapid
improvement throughout
you know after we got through the peak
of the pandemic april may
june we were making really significant
improvement through the summer
again the fall started to see a pickup
in
in covid cases and it set us back
until the early part of this year and
we're starting to see again a pickup in
economic activity i expect that that's
going to accelerate
um i mentioned um remote work
is a really critical um issue
emerging um it has implications things
that you folks deal with
um you know i'm not prepared to talk
about but you know
how how we tax workers that live in one
place
and work in another all of those issues
that are gonna make their way to the
supreme court i assume
um but the interesting thing is um
you know we've seen a pickup
in our employment but we haven't seen
as significant a return to daily
trips to workplaces in the state again
another private sector
source high frequency done every day
this data is produced google
as you know collects data on where you
are based on your location of your cell
phone
and they translate that or turn that
into what they call their mobility
reports and you can get this data
at the state level and also at the
county level
so it varies by county in new hampshire
but what it shows
is that you know during the peak of the
pandemic people weren't
traveling to work so it dropped almost
50 percent
it picked up again as people went back
to work but it has leveled off
and it's leveled off partly because we
still have people
who are collecting unemployment and are
not going to work but also
a really significant increase in remote
work that is likely
to be maintained prior to the pandemic
we had maybe seven percent of
of our workforce that was working
remotely either all or part of the time
i think by the end of the pin you know
but when it finally all shakes out we'll
probably be in the 15 percent range
maybe a little bit higher that has some
real significant
implications one is
people are kind of getting used to
remote work and they're expecting it
and i said this to i spoke to human
resource
people a couple of weeks ago you better
have a plan
in your organization for how do you
handle that not everybody wants to work
at home full-time but a lot of them want
some hybrid
you know working a few days a week at
home or a couple of days a week at home
and that will have some impact i think
on
you know who gets hired in new hampshire
versus
again hired in another state but living
in new hampshire
that remote work and i think i showed
this chart in january
is a great opportunity as well as
you know a potential threat the
opportunity is when people can live
anywhere they want and it doesn't have
to be next to their work they choose to
live in places
that you know are more attractive new
hampshire is one of those places so
two of our neighbors who we tend to
attract people
from who tend to move here are
massachusetts and connecticut and they
are both
they both have a lot of uh telework
teleworkers they saw large increases in
the in the
number of businesses that said they
increased their
telework opportunities new hampshire was
number four on the list by the way
so um i expect that that presents us
with an opportunity and i'll show you
some data that suggests that's actually
happening
that more people are going to live in
new hampshire not necessarily
work here and oh by the way
that has really been you know that's
that is really the story behind new
hampshire's
great um industrial transformation that
happened in the 70s and
in the 80s we had a lot we were
attracting a lot of people because we
had cheaper
housing and you know much cheaper we
don't have
as we still have cheaper but not as
cheap
relative to other states and it was just
a great place to live
those people many of them continue to
work in massachusetts
or somewhere else but eventually
you know they became a real part of our
labor force companies recognized that we
had this
upskilling in our labor force and you
know we became a place that people said
oh
you know if we locate there we can
attract some of that talent so that's
the potential
the downside is is that also the remote
work will
allow those people to live here and even
if
there are people who have lived here
forever
there's going to be more companies
coming after our talent so we're going
to have to compete
um you know more it's going to be more
competition for the skilled workers and
we have a lot of them in our state
so it's going to be great for us
demographically it is already starting
to be very good for us demographically
on the remote work trend but it's also
going to present
our employers with a challenge in terms
of competing
for those workers and oh by the way i
look at
you know wage structures and you know we
don't offer the same wage rates as
you know some of our neighbors
particularly in massachusetts
and if you don't have the cost of
commuting boy that's an easy decision to
to you know to work for an employer um
in that state
still live in new hampshire to really
benefit from that maximize we're going
to have to
you know we're going to have to keep get
some of those workers to work in new
hampshire as well
i mentioned the um you know the benefit
in terms of remote working
we're seeing it this is again private
sector data it's from realtor.com
and it looked at online views of homes
for sale
in different areas i broke it it's a
very busy chart i apologize for that but
there's two massachusetts um
read counties there and there at the
bottom and it what this shows is the
year-over-year change in
the online views of homes for sale i
will tell you i looked at this
nationally i looked at it in a lot of
places new hampshire
had two to three times
the increase that most other places had
i mean there are some other rural states
that had
similar but in the northeast um you know
new hampshire got
more interest in um you know home views
people looking to move here and we're
we're seeing it anecdotally in terms of
you know home purchases
one of the things on my to-do list is to
look at where
the homes that are bought where the
buyers come from but anecdotally we
are hearing more out-of-state buyers
interestingly
about this data is that some of our more
rural
counties saw the biggest increase
grafton county
being one of them belknap county
so kind of the you know people were not
only looking
compared to looking in suffolk and
middlesex county where we tend to get
a lot of people from they were looking
new hampshire but
within new hampshire they were
increasing their views
a little bit further north you know so i
think again that
bodes well for the demographics of some
of those
counties fortunately unfortunately
representative tucker
there weren't enough data for coast
county to show what happened there i
wish
we did have that data because i think
that would be terrific as well
but it is a positive trend it indicates
that you know more people are interested
in
in new hampshire just adding to your
factual base i get a postcard about
every two
two and a half weeks urging me to
consider selling my home
yeah yeah i get a lot of those too i get
phone calls and texts
i live in the southern part of the state
but i was getting texts and phone calls
and i just didn't respond um but you
know there's
there's not a lot of supply and so
you know if there were if there were a
greater supply we would see
more people we would see great in
migration here
and in my county better broadband
yeah oh yeah i mean again first
requirement
oh yeah and and you know it's this is a
wonderful the remote work
phenomena is a wonderful opportunity for
some of our more rural
regions unfortunately that is you know
there's a
that's one of those you know
prerequisites
that's going to maybe definitely impede
some regions that could benefit from
that trend um that's been true for a
while but here we have this very
i think unique opportunity um
to increase our our rate of um you know
in migration
which is important and and which by the
way gets to this slide
yesterday there was a report again about
new hampshire's population growth and
slower than massachusetts
look message i i eliminated one of the
charts i was going to put in here
our the way we grow is very different
massachusetts
has pretty strong birth rates
um for new england so they have you know
they they get a lot of international
migration and they get
you know they have higher birth rates
because they have demographics that tend
to have higher birth rates
new hampshire traditionally oh and i've
looked at this data for 20 years
has either the number one or number two
lowest birth rate of any state in the
nation
that does a couple of things it one
makes your median age rise pretty
quickly because the quickest
the easiest way to get your median age
or keep it low is to add
individuals at age zero meaning birth
rates
so we have and this is not going to
change by the web
by the way because we have and i've said
this before probably in this committee
we have women who participate in the
labor force at very high rates and we
have well educated women and that is a
recipe for lower
birth rates that's not going to change
so the way we will grow
is attracting individuals by in that in
migration that is absolutely critical to
our population growth we are fortunate
in new england
that you know unlike massachusetts which
tends to see net outmigration
we and connecticut we tend to see net in
migration
so when in-migration picks up it's a
benefit to us
remote work provides a additional
opportunity for us to bolster that it
had been picking up
anyway it's also picking up
interestingly
among younger populations um
traditionally we had
attracted a lot of 30 to 44 45 year old
married couple families with kids we you
know
import our kids but it's moved down a
little bit
so we're seeing more in the 25 to 29
year old it tends to be located in
certain communities
but overall that whole
notion of of in-migration is really
critical to our to our population and
labor force growth
um minus
0.76 oh i'm sorry that's a
a measure of the relationship the
correlation between those two variables
so if if the two variables
median age and fertility rates
moved exactly the same meaning if if the
fertility rate
absolutely determined the median age
you'd see a one
a value of one there
but there's other factors that play into
it too so it's a little bit lower so
that number varies from um
you know from plus 1 to negative 1. so
what that shows that negative
76 shows that 0.76 shows that
the relationship is is strong and
negative so the higher the birth rate
the lower the median age
and the lower the or the higher the
median aids the lower the birth rate
or the lower the um median age the
higher the birth rate however you want
to look at it
so it's a strong relationship and you
can see it there that line that runs
through it
as you move to the right you know utah
is down at the bottom
they have very very high birth rates
large mormon families
they also have the lowest median age of
any
state in the nation so birth rates are
critical it's a big reason why our
median age is high
i've done demographic presentations
where i show
we you know we don't have the you know
people say we're the oldest state we
don't have the highest percentage
or second highest percent second highest
median age we don't have the second
or first highest percentage of
individuals over you know what
considered
um you know senior citizens we don't
we're you know we're high but
somewhere in the order of you know 15th
or 14th somewhere like that
but it's the fact that we have these
very low birth rates that really
contribute to our median beating ace as
true in vermont as well
um looking at that migration i you know
again this
i could go back much further here um a
couple of decades where you'd see
years where we had you know between
regularly between 15 and 20
000 net domestic meaning more people
moving into new hampshire from another
state than left
this just shows the most recent um you
know 20 years
and you know it had been declining in
the 2000s it went negative in that
um you know starting with the great
recession and you know
and a bit afterwards um
it was difficult to move here because
most of people that moved here would
have had to sell a house somewhere else
because of the
demographics of who he had attracted and
they would have wanted to buy a house
here
both of those things were difficult
largely because selling a house during
that time period meant a lot of people
were still underwater
anyway a lot of reasons why we saw
net domestic out migration that was a
very bad
sign for new hampshire it wasn't you
know
just young people leaving um young
people
have been leaving the state and they
leave all rural states
for decades it was the fact that we
weren't seeing our typical
group um you know level of people moving
into the state that
that you know had been characteristic
for the prior few decades
so it picked up again near the end of
the decade and i think this year
and i may be even a little bit
understating what could happen in those
outer years
2020 i think we'll be up around 6 500.
and i've i you know i ratcheted it down
a little bit because i don't want to
i don't want to be hyperbolic but that's
you know that's a very
positive um level you know if we can
continue to keep approximately at that
level that helps
make that um median age a little bit
more stationary it's not
up in the 10 000 range which would
really help if you can add a lot of
people in the middle
you know and that even now we're adding
more 25 to 30
29 but if you even if you add people in
that 30 to 40
which is traditionally who we've
attracted the most
you keep your median age from rising
significantly
because it's not going to be lowered by
a lot of babies being born that's just
not happening it's not go
it's not going to happen in new
hampshire um i'm getting close to the
end here
my job forecast way different than the
last time i was here
which i think was a little over one
percent there and then
up to around you know just under three
percent for 2022. so
i'm basically saying 3.8 percent for
2021 2.7
for 2022. now i do recognize
that the the exactly when that falls
could change so it could be
2.7 or 2.5 in 2021
and then well over three in 2022 so the
exact timing that's a little bit
different
but i think if you average you know we
we gain you know about six percent six
and a half percent that now that puts us
right near getting back to full
employment by the end of that
or where we were prior to the pandemic
by 2022 and
certainly in 2012 by 2023 we will be
we'll have regained all those jobs
um again so i'm going to go back to this
chart
which i showed at the very beginning
where we were prior to the pandemic
where i had forecast before the pandemic
where we would be
in a couple of years where we are now
the red line
so what is that forecast that i just
showed you imply
and it implies this one that again
we get back to
um you know where we were prior to the
pandemic
somewhere later in 2022
and then we about a year later before we
get back up to
trend where we were the rate at which we
were growing
prior to the pandemic
so it it will take time um my guess
is that it will feel a lot better than
the actual numbers i think you know
we're going to see
hiring we're going to see a lot of
economic activity
but because we lost so many of those
jobs um
those the numbers are still it's not
going to look as
looking at this chart it's not going to
look like a roaring economy but i do
think
you know we're on the verge of of really
a really strong economic
um you know for at least a year probably
a year and a half and maybe a little bit
beyond that
um gdp growth this is my forecast for
gdp again
i i will regain our gdp much quicker
than
than our jobs partly because we a lot of
the jobs that we lost were
you know what are considered lower
productivity jobs jobs that
don't generate as much
gross product um and the jobs that we're
adding
again it gets back to that chart of the
wages that i showed the jobs lost
much lower wages the the jobs that we
gained were much higher
so we're making that trade-off of higher
value-added jobs
being gained lower and that contributes
to us getting our gdp level back before
we get our
all of our jobs back now
things that you're really interested in
and i apologize i
you know i in the past have done a lot
of revenue work
on different aspects of revenue really
didn't have time to do that but i just
put together a couple of charts
this is a chart that shows business tax
revenues combined
bet and bpt revenues and it's a it's
each of those points on that line is
the 12 months prior to the sum of the 12
months prior
so it gives you an idea of the
annualized
um bpt
and be business taxes and what you see
really interestingly obviously
you know the recession there was a big
drop um
didn't you know grow that much early
from in recovery from the great
recession the big
change here is what happened after you
know the tax reform or whatever you want
to call it uh you know in 2018
and you knew this a big anomalous
increase
in business tax revenues huge increase
that was going to decline and was
beginning to decline
prior to the pandemic the pandemic made
it
decline even more but it's bounced back
again
and it's bounced back so it's above
trend line the trend line
is that red you know series of dots so
it's really above
you know it's above trend and
so obviously some you know there's been
some fundamental changes as a result of
that
of the reform act that's yielded more
more revenue even in a in a relatively
weaker
um economy um taking a look
at kind of i want to make that
distinction between how the business
taxes re
perform and how the non-business taxes
reform and so i look at
i tend to look at the nine largest what
i call economically sensitive revenue
sources
you know you have plenty of revenue
sources that just don't really vary
much by by the um you know by economic
conditions
you know you know fines uh
you know that doesn't really change so i
look at the ones that tend to vary by
um and they they represent the bulk of
of revenue so this is
um what on a percentage basis the
same thing taking the sum of uh
you know the prior 12 months how
revenues have changed
when you look at all of those nine
largest sources so
big increases prior to the to the great
recession big declines
during the great recession and then had
these ups and downs until you had a big
increase again
with after the 2018
changes the federal tax laws so big
increase saw again a decrease
um with the pandemic but that's
including
you know business taxes when you look at
what's happened with
not you know excluding the business
taxes a couple of things stand out when
i look at this chart one
is that for most of the time period
those two
measures kind of varied the same so
when non-business taxes grew business
taxes tended to grow and
grow you know at us not exactly the same
pace
but similar so you know it it made sense
revenues both business and non-business
revenues
reflected more economic the economic
conditions
again when you look at what happened
in the uh following the the the
tax changes the federal tax changes in
when you add in business taxes a big
increase but when you look at
non-business taxes
you know there was kind of the typical
growth
you know it was growing two percent or a
little under two percent it did pick up
it
just before the pandemic but it
declined it didn't decline as much as
with the business taxes but it gives you
an idea that we've
sort of made a break since the
tax reform or tax changes at the federal
level
seen a little bit of a break in terms of
that historical relationship between
um and i you know i don't know exactly
what
how to attribute that and i don't know
how long it will last
i'm sure you folks have much better idea
than do i
but it is interesting because um
you know we tend to focus a lot on on
the business tax changes but you know
if you look at the long-term trend and
the non-business taxes it's not nearly
you know if it's not nearly as favorable
i mean it's you know pretty modest
growth um so it's really been the
business tax changes and particularly
the business
tax revenue changes since the 2018
that's really
been the driving force be behind what's
um
you know what's happened with our
revenue so um you know any changes
that are made to that are you know are
going to really represent the bulk of
of what happens to revenues over the
next couple of years
and i know this was a topic of interest
so
on very short notice i looked at data
on ppp loans
and i didn't have time to break it out
by industry
but i did have time last evening to
break it out
by the type of organization because i
think it has implications
i don't know um you know the discussions
around taxing
um those grants and whether they're
loans or grants
i i you know i confess to not having
followed that very closely
but this gives you an idea you know
overall there was
almost 3.6 billion dollars in ppp loans
through april
13th that had been issued to new
organizations in new hampshire um the
bulk of that
um went to corporations llcs and llps
limited liability partnerships
sub-chapter s
corporations so when you add that
outside what 85
or so um or close to it
of those loans went to
um you know organizations that are
likely
you know a significant portion of who
pays the bpt and the bet
now i put in red here the sole
proprietorships
because i'm a little bit skeptical this
data
is you know reported by the lender and
by sba
but i looked at that sole proprietorship
data and i looked at
loans over 150k and i
spotted some names and i didn't go
through the whole list
but of cour of organizations that are
not sole proprietorships
they you know a 3.2 million dollar
ppp loan to a sole proprietorship i
don't think so and i know the company so
and i know they're not a sole
proprietorship so i'm a little bit
skeptical of this
my guess is a fair amount of this that's
in the sole proprietorship
winds up being in one of these up here
um so this gives you an idea of
you know what's out there and how it's
distributed and i don't know
exactly how that helps you but i thought
i would include it
because i know it's of interest and um
that's my last slide and i'm
happy to talk uh or take questions i
hope i didn't miss questions along the
way
brian that was an excellent presentation
i got more out of it than i thought i
would and
you had low expectations i always meet
low expectations representative major
actually uh you provided information i
didn't think
it was going to be available and i
i certainly appreciate such a short
schedule responding and presenting this
to us
so questions from the committee
representative the model
thank you for taking a question uh i
noticed in the beginning
one of the first slides about half of
the new hampshire population is employed
is is that how does that statistic
line up with other states well um
yeah i mean you what you need to do and
i don't have it off the top my head is
the employment the population ratio
um but it's really what you want to do
is look at
the the um the population that is
of employable age so 16
above and um we generally have
um a you know a higher than i don't know
off the top my head where we're at
but that is actually and i usually don't
include
that metric in my presentation because
a lot of people aren't familiar with it
but when you really want to know where
where we're at you take a look at that
that
ratio of people who are working to the
you know the potential working age
population
so not just who's in the labor force but
the potential labor force
and that gives you really a good idea of
where you're at
and it gives it would give us a really
good um
idea of how you know how our
economy is performing relative to prior
to the
uh to the um the pandemic
and i will look at that and get back to
you on that because
you made me think that maybe i should
start including it i i
i struggle with it because it's a little
bit harder metric
to explain in a in a in a presentation
but it's really an important one so the
ratio of people who are working to those
in the the working age population is
really an important metric
and would that change with um with the
tele it probably i mean
in theory it could um i don't know of
any research that's
shown that i mean i guess you know one
theory is that
the ability to work from home will
unlock some
individuals who are unable to
work or enter the labor force because
of you know either you know home care or
health or whatever or
or disability issues so in theory
you know that could potentially i don't
know that it would make
a huge difference um i do know that you
know
every everywhere that ratio has declined
because more people have stepped out of
the labor force
um either because they had to or because
they lost their jobs but
a lot of it's you know simply because
people haven't been
you know there's fewer people who are
able to work again women in particular
have
have you know had their labor force
participation cut back because they're
primary
caregivers and that burden generally
falls on them there's fewer of those
opportunities
um but it's a it's a really important
metric
and i it's an interesting point because
i hadn't thought of that the potential
that it could
you know it would be you know it's not
going to increase it by a percent but it
might increase it by some
you know if it could increase that
employment to population ratio
you know a few tenths of a percent
that's still
very important that would be a very
important increase
thank you reps and ames
um hi um thanks for that very good
presentation um do you track
data on the numbers of school-aged
children
in new hampshire and changes over time
what's happening happening now yeah i
mean you know that that data
it's not a very high frequency data you
know and it's an estimate
um we do the best day that we have
is um in terms what comes from the
department of education in terms of
enrollments
um you know that gives us some idea
um the you know the population data
comes out on an annual basis an estimate
but
yeah we you know i don't have a um
a strong use for that data but i am
aware of it and we do know that that
it has been declining um because we know
enrollments have been declining
um interestingly though during the
pandemic we saw some unexpected
increases in some of our rural school
districts
again you know it was people who were
looking to you know the the move toward
less density
you know people moving from more densely
populated areas
picking you know whether again whether
they stay and remain but
i heard anecdotally you know from
from some school districts had
unexpected increases in fall enrollments
this past year and a lot of that had to
do with people
just you know looking for you know to to
leave areas that were more densely
populated for health pandemic reasons
related reasons but we do have that um
you know i don't have a regular use for
it
um but we do have it yeah
okay thank you just some more statistics
on
enrollment uh when
representation and i were on the
education funding committee back in 99
there was about 210 000
registered students grades 1 to 12
in new hampshire and now i guess that
number has come down to about 176
thousand so
that's a big problem and it's dropping
every year
yep that's an elliott followed by
representative elmi
yes uh brian thank you for that
wonderful presentation
i'm just wondering if all of that
information is going to be lost to us
or whether someone is going to mail to
the members of the committee
that entire presentation that you just
gave
because my iq is about one-tenth of
yours
i need time to study those things
yeah bob i i brian said he was going to
email that to jennifer and jenna
jennifer will get it to every member of
the committee
wonderful yeah and and if you have
questions after you
look it over and i know i you know i
present a lot and i do it
too quickly and not always as cogently
as i could
um if you you know when you look at it
and you have questions feel free
to contact me and i'll do my best i'm
not sure i'll have the answers but i'll
do my best to
you know i'll make something up if i
don't have the answers if i want
you know you should know me well enough
to know that i am frequently in air but
rarely in doubt
i say that all the time what email
should we use
um use my nhes
email jennifer has it thank you
representative
thank you mr chairman uh brian
is that have you looked at a
relationship between the fertility rate
and
labor force participation are those
trade-offs
yeah there is a trade-off and i and um
you know lower fertility rates are
generally associated with a couple of
things
women who participate in the labor force
at high rates and higher levels of
educational attainment
so i you know it is
you know i say some of our demographics
are the result of our successes not our
failures
one of our successes or a couple of them
is that we have women who
participate in the labor force at high
rates and
because they have they're well educated
and they have higher skills
than a lot of states and that is a
recipe for
you know for low fertility rates so it
is you know it does provide a benefit
it doesn't mean you know when i look at
um
you know the child care issue and how
that impedes the labor force it tends to
impede labor force at
um you know lower among women who have
lower levels of education
and skill attainment which is really
unfortunate because those are
individuals who would
you know their lives that would benefit
the most from the ability to participate
in labor force
um but so you know
generally having you know children
if you have a higher level of
educational attainment generally you're
going to have a lower fertility
families are smaller so
it is a there is a definite relationship
there's no doubt about it
there's definite relation i mean there
are other factors that enter into it but
it plays a strong role
represented hacking phillips
here i'm along the same line of
discussion
um brian i'm wondering um is there a way
to isolate
what proportion of the population has
has you know self-selected to step out
of the labor force
yes what kind of what are we looking at
there
well um the way we do it here i've done
it here
is one of the new programs
that was established by the federal
government to deal
with people affected by the pandemic is
the
pandemic unemployment assistance program
and people have to
basically certify um as to why
they are unable to work and they they're
given a number of choices one of them
is health reasons one is having to take
care of somebody who has a health reason
and that one of the
health reasons is you know some you have
to have a doctor say that
you know you should not have be in an
environment you know
for this reason or whatever um another
one is
uh i needed to take care of a child who
is not in school or in a daycare
um during the pandemic and that's a
you know that's an important one that
just to give you some numbers is
somewhere over
you know around 3 000 currently it's
gone down somewhat
you know at school it's more schools
have opened up now that's just a portion
of people who aren't in the labor force
because of child care issues because
there's people who weren't
collecting weren't working before who
aren't in the workforce because
you know they never they or they've been
out of the labor force for some reason
so the child care issue contribute
this is just one who for people who were
working
stepped out of the labor force or unable
to work because they had to attend to
you know take care of a child for that
reason there are a few other reasons
but we do have that and we actually have
some you know his i have historical data
on historical meaning
going back to probably sometime in the
summer
and so i can track that
representative spillsbury thank you mr
chairman
brian it's an extraordinary presentation
i think especially because of the broad
range of metrics you've shown us
things like uh online
uh home searches and so on yeah but i
have two questions
uh from the chart you showed us
of the trend lines for new hampshire
revenue
right right both the bet bpt and then
the the non um
the first question is there was a very
marked surge above trend
coming into 19 and before the pandemic
and uh you you did mention the influence
of
the 2018 federal tax law changes
but are there other factors that you
think were
drivers of that surge and uh
where do those perhaps stand coming
out of the pan batman yeah i i don't
know i think
you know if i were to think about one
more recently
you know i mean i think the ppp loans
probably have some impact
um and and i think and the reason i
think that is
um and and i i don't know how those are
accounted for i'm not an accountant i
have no
accounting background but if if into if
companies are
you know if that provides grants as
opposed to loans to companies
obviously that's going to you know help
their
potentially help their profitability or
their bottom line
you know if if if they're able to
um you know to pay for some of their
costs
in that fashion um and it's not coming
out
of their operating revenue i would
assume
that it would increase their
profitability so that may account for
some of it
out coming you know as we went long
longer in the pandemic
i don't know you know i don't know all
the particulars in terms of the tax
law changes in 2018 and how i mean i've
heard
but honestly i didn't focus a lot on it
i think more recently
a couple of things happen when you come
out start to come out of a recession
generally profitability spikes anyway
it spikes because companies are leaner
you know they've they've done whatever
they can to cut their expenses
so as as an economy is coming out of
recession
profits tend to really pop they tend to
really jump
to the extent that maybe ppp loans play
into that because companies are not
using operating revenue
for expenses theoretically and again i'm
not an accountant so i don't know how
they account for those it might make
their profitability increase even more
interestingly you know the ppp loans
have changed the january of this year
loans which is about just over a billion
of that 3.6 billion
those are supposedly only going to
companies that
had at least a 25 decline in their
revenue
during the pandemic or the past year so
those might not have the same impact in
terms of profitability
uh you know as the ones that you know
the companies that got loans regardless
of whether they had lost profitability
there was no criteria
in the first round the 2.5 billion that
went to new hampshire
there was no criteria for a company
having experienced a loss
in revenue um so in theory those
could be you know that money could
have gone to companies as long as 60 of
it went
for payroll um it becomes a grant
and in that case i i have a hard time
thinking it doesn't
help their profitability
thank you i mean it strikes me from that
chart that
we were fortunate in uh having such a
robust economy
yeah and the pandemic hit sure the other
question from that same charity is i
noticed a
particular spike in the non-business tax
revenue sources yeah about 2016.
so uh having not been uh in this scene
at that time i'm wondering if you can
tell us
which element of our taxes uh surged
then and why i can't to be honest with
you
um i had i had a little bit more time i
would have prepared
um you know i i said i used to do a lot
more
um uh when i was in the private sector
for a lot of reasons i did a lot more
looking at individual revenues i still
maintain the database but i just don't
analyze it
the way i used to um so i you know off
the top of my head i just didn't look at
it enough to
to to be able to answer that i apologize
there has to be i don't know if there if
there were you know
a particular revenue source um that
jumped
um and it very well may be because
but i would have to go back and look um
to see which ones
um increase the most i mean generally
they increase when the economy is strong
and
you know in it was really in that
2015-16
time period when things really started
to get much better in new hampshire
you know we started to see really
significant it took us
quite a while to really emerge from the
from the great recession
we were growing more slowly than
a lot of places there was a lot of
concern i know among
lawmakers government officials and
everybody
my goodness the worst thing you could
say is that we were growing more slowly
than
adding fewer jobs in massachusetts on a
percentage basis
and worse than that there was times when
vermont was adding
jobs at a higher rate oh my god you know
cats and dogs were sleeping together the
world was very near
the end um but
you know eventually we caught up and you
know it accelerated
and there's a you know i can speculate
at another time on why some of that
happened but it was in that time period
where we really started to see an
increase and i think that contributed to
some of it but
in terms of specific revenues off the
top of my head i don't know i do have it
but i just
i haven't looked at it enough detail
well thank you you're covered a lot
like representative elliott i'm looking
forward to sitting down and reviewing
the hard copy
i think we all are ah
i hope i'm not quizzed on it later
because
no quizzes all right and if you quiz you
gotta i gotta be graded on a curve
we're coming back at you uh i don't see
any more hands raised
and again brian uh we all appreciate
on such a short notice which you put
together
to share with us today so thank you yep
my pleasure always enjoy talking uh uh
to you folks
um and i always you know get food for
thought when i do
things that i didn't think about or
things that i should look at
so you know i always get a lot out of it
as well so thank you
well you helped us look at a lot of that
food for thoughts
great okay um
that's a couple things i want to go over
with the committee
um
just as soon as we hear from
emily brock
about he figured that the treasure is
going to release the
rules monday and if
she can analyze that
and help us out then maybe
it should be i might be able to get her
to
join us on wednesday when we talk
revenues
[Music]
you should have both everybody should
have received
by now
the amendment for senate bill 27
which is authored by representative
romney
and the amendment on senate bill 101
authored by rebs and early and elmi
and so that you'll have these when we
have
the work session on tuesday
on the senate bills that we're going to
go over
we have seven remaining senate senate
bills and they've all
all been scheduled for a work session
next tuesday
dec aims he sent me
an email uh
relative to california when i mentioned
this past week at california
the week before the senate had passed
a change to the
their laws to allow
california to deduct the
loan from their income
and it was in the other house and then
represent ames you want to talk about
what you had sent an email to me
what happened this week in california
sure
just very quickly um
the california had this pending bill it
actually goes back a year
um but they've been considering
conforming like us they don't
automatically conform
and they delayed
um after the arpa enactment
because of concern that the tax cuts
provision in there that we've been
talking about
might be triggered by a
conformity decision in other words the
tax relief
is essentially a a tax cut
and if that
was the kind of tax cut that's in uh
that's within the the scope of the tax
cuts provision
and arpa then um
you can't use opera money
to fill in behind that tax cut
apparently they were satisfied by that i
haven't seen any explanation
satisfied that that wouldn't happen in
other words
and i agree with them that the
information from
treasury makes clear that
conforming simply conforming your code
to the federal
tax exemption provisions will not
trigger that cut so they went forward
with their conformity provisions so what
did they do
in conforming it's a little more than
just conforming
it's trimming at the edges and one of
the interesting provisions is that they
uh took out
excluded from the exemption
that will that applies under federal law
and will now apply in california
um publicly traded companies
why i don't know but that's a pretty
significant
exclusion maybe not huge because
of the 500 employee limitation anyway in
the ppp program
but certainly something to be aware of
the other reason i sent that out
is that they they through their
i think it's called the california
franchise board
did a impact analysis
they call an economic and impact when
they're talking about
revenues and
came out with a significant cost
to doing this in california of course
california is huge and we're tiny
but the impact was about six billion
dollars
of uh lost revenue that would result
from this that's under both the personal
income
tax in california and the business tax
um but it's a big amount of money and
and uh i thought if we could
get our hands on that analysis it
certainly would be
helpful to dra into ways and means
to see if we're either missing something
or maybe california has looked at
something differently than
we're looking at it obviously there are
differences in our taxes
so that's maybe it's not all relevant
but
uh but it's worth looking at and
that's why i sent it down
thank you dick and i guess that's on its
way to the governor's office to be
signed
yeah it's in his office it passed both
houses
i don't know let's say monday or tuesday
and
now it's there and he's said to be
in support of it okay
yesterday um i received
two more emails uh what i'm both from
walters pillsbury
and uh and walter i just haven't had
time because i'm
tied up with a medical things yesterday
and so
uh they're both
very interesting and one has to do
with what we heard the other day
from chris where money was taken out of
various funds directly state of health
and human services or to fund
building or any other thing and
we need more information on that and i
think what i'll do
is i'll concentrate to have
before the committee a better
explanation
on this and it's a good catch
the other one has to do with uh
representative schamberg and you
talking together about coming up with an
amendment
for senate bill 3 do you want to mention
that
uh sure um
i i think it may take a work session
to gauge the sentiment of the committee
and
what direction uh the group seems
inclined to take hp3 but
i'm concerned from the testimony that we
heard on tuesday
that uh if there's a political desire
to move with hb3 and
essentially stake a position that we're
not trying to tax
things that were grants for a hardship
but we may nevertheless need an
amendment
that limits the extent to which uh
specific
expenses can be utilized twice and so
uh i think the discussion it's going to
require us to have
is whether our motivation uh for hb3
is a perception that businesses are
being subjected to attacks
uh that is an unanticipated burden
or whether actually this is providing a
whole new source of stimulus a second
benefit
and is that a good public policy to do
it so
um the amendment that i'm considering
i alluded to the other day and
representative schamberg has indicated
that he'd like to
participate haven't thought through
language
but it would be something that would
limit the ability to do that
the same expense twice
i think it's worthwhile to have that
amendment ready
and whether we use it or not
at least have it ready and
we can discuss it
i did receive another email
yesterday from susan and
along with it was a report for the
worldwide combined reporting and i have
susan i have not had an opportunity to
read that bit
you may want to just give a quick
summary of that
on yes well on i've
actually distributed it among the
democrats now most of whom were involved
in this
but last year we also had a bill from
tom schamberg about on
instituting worldwide combined reporting
which is a fairly complicated issue
and the whole committee both parties
were
interested in learning more about this
on the pandemic got in our way very
badly
we could not get on
brent bandwidth from the state
to hold a meeting
a public meeting of both parties and
we went ahead with the uh
principal advocates of this
which include a very interesting group
of
businesses that started in the midwest
which are domestically based uh and
on we had a
um a very informative meeting in
in october of last year
and uh there was an enormous amount of
stuff going on
with the election and everything like
that uh
so it is just um
last two weeks ago that
when we took a break that i managed to
get back
and finish uh pulling together
all of the comments of of those
participants who spoke to us
um and on checking
back with everybody about it being an
accurate portrayal
and that is what i just passed on to
chair major i wanted him to decide when
and how
he uses it because on i think right now
we're still
we're working on revenues we're still
working on bills
but pretty soon our committee
which last year voted during the interim
study
votes to to uh
ask representative schamberg to bring
back his bills so that we could have
this discussion in
in public um
is um we
um we are going to be we did retain the
bill and we are going to be
discussing it i'm not whenever the chair
desires i just thought it would be good
to have that report
out so people would have a
kind of cliff's notes to the whole
discussion before we started bringing
back people
thank you so we can send that report out
to
all the members of representative
romney
you're muted i think i think he had her
hand up first
i know it couldn't minus go ahead
oh okay i just want to go back to uh
representative spillsberry and um a
potential amendment with uh
representative schomburg
so first thing i guess we once that is
created we should
have that scored by finance as to what
the impact is is that
your intention uh walter well that
certainly makes sense yes
i'll need your coaching on the process
my first time doing it
well we just have to ask them that's all
it won't be it won't be difficult but
so my understanding is that the federal
gov
the feds when they were doing this when
they let the federal legislature was
doing this
that this was debated whether there
should be this
second uh stimulus if you will because
that's what it is
and uh they went back and forth but then
they they agreed yes let's
let's do this second thing which was yes
deductions were always going to be there
for the expenses
but then at the last minute they added
in
the fact that if a loan is forgiven
that it not be treated as revenue
so uh that's what we're debating here is
should that be
considered as revenue or not uh
basically it's
cash that came in but when it comes to
the
you know you have your books right you
have revenue you have expense
you subtract the two you get profit the
profit's what's taxed
so what we're debating here is whether
that that
forgiven revenue that forgiven
uh loan be treated as revenue
or not and uh so if we take it out
obviously uh in theory
uh the profits are going to be be less
so yes it is it is the
double benefit to those companies and uh
i think again it was a the legislature
the federal legislature was aware that
it was a double benefit
and they did and they decided to do it
now
and i to me there's no question i think
what we're trying to do now is
understand what the total financial
impact and i would say it's going to
come in in the 100 million
range um you know we're still waiting to
hear from the dra
um and there's a whole bunch of
variables here
we're going to be considering you know
if the if the uh 91.9
trillion dollar program whatever we're
getting out of that
uh we're allowed to offset this
then it becomes less of an issue with
100 million
it appears that we have enough revenue
coming in this year to
help offset that as well so
i i think this is going to boil down to
a political decision at the end
because we could be right but then we
could be wrong by being right
is my interpretation of it you know we
we could have all the arguments of why
this may not be a good idea
but um and i think senator bradley
expressed it the best he obviously his
was a political
the senate's calculus was political
when i asked him when i asked him well
well
did you have do you have a problem with
the 91
whatever it was million or did the
senate have any problem
and they said no we didn't even have a
problem with 135 million
they thought that that was doable so to
me
it was in uh in the world of uh
how do we want to treat our businesses
how it's going to be perceived it's more
perception than
uh the numbers at this point but that's
just my opinion we'll talk about it next
tuesday again
on wednesday probably but i think that's
where we're at with this
um and i think each of us is going to
have to make a decision
as to um you know
yeah we first thing we have to do is
agree to the numbers
that dra has given us and that's that's
not over they're still working them
uh and then we have to make a decision
as to
whether we think we can absorb that and
uh given our
current revenues that are coming in and
what we think of
next year uh and and we have to make
evaluate
you know how our businesses
understanding that it's not every
business are going to proceed
i'm sorry i'm long-winded on this but um
that's where i think we're adam with
this one
thank you okay before i go to
representative tucker is that
on senate bill three we're going to deal
with the data
and we should make a decision based on
that
and then anything if then if
people above us
above our pay grade disagree with them
and they will let us know
but i think we need to make a decision
based upon
what we think is best for the state of
new hampshire
relative to the data representative
tucker
yes i had a very simple question could
could you just tell us again
which day next week if any you think
we'll be having executive session
i don't plan on having any executive
session next year
what we got from the office
said that wednesday was a day that we
could expect
executive sessions to take place but
that's not the case
i want to make sure because i have to
step out for
a bit yeah at this point in time i
do not plan to have any executive
sessions next week
because we have a lot of time between
then
and the 26.
thank you very much but what i want what
i expect on
on tuesday when we do the work sessions
is that we come out of it identifying
those
bills that we have enough information so
that when we have an executive session
we can vote on it
and those bills that we don't have
enough information who do we call back
and those bills that there's two
amendments coming up for two bills and
if that
is satisfactory then we're all set on
that too
and uh that said and then on wednesday
that would be to
pick up revenue issues
great good i i thought that's what you
said and then when i saw the agenda
i just thought i'd check right
they always put that on there just in
case
thank you very much if there's going to
be an executive session i will let you
know ahead of time
thank you
representative element thank you
i want to get back to the sb
3. i think that that
it's going to be very important
that we have something like what
representative spillsbury
is talking about that makes it clear
that we are not going to be in the
business
in future of on making all federal
grants
tax-free that would pretty much kill us
i think
um but there are two other things there
one of them
is that on i checked the attendees
and there wasn't anybody from dra
present and i think that
we ought to share with them that on
the security uh the uh
[Music]
employment security department has got
some interesting information on ppp that
they don't have
and the second one is
i think probably we would not be allowed
to do this by our constitution
but the first part of
the uh ppp grants the larger part of it
did not include any requirement as
brian gottlobe was saying
to show that you'd experience some kind
of loss
from the pandemic and so a lot of
businesses that
really didn't have a loss on applied for
it and got it
and they were frequently the ones that
got it first because
they had banking relationships that were
better than the rest
on and if we're talk if
the federal government considered this
as a stimulus and if we're talking
about uh accepting it as a stimulus
the state will also do which i think is
the
issue on is there a way
that we could require that the criteria
that
are in the second part of
ppp applied
to the first part i don't know whether
that would be too difficult for us to
manage administratively
i don't know what at this point whether
constitutionally
we could do that but it would
limit it to the companies that really
needed to keep that money that
that spent it all and didn't get any
profits during that period
and are trying to stay alive yeah
we need more clarity on both
types of stimulus what the rules were
because brian said something
that contrary to what i thought because
i thought the first people
take tpp loans
i know a friend of mine said that they
weren't eligible because they started in
november and they made less so that's
contrary to what
he said that was actually true
that's a different group that's the
group that started
on up businesses too late for
the ppp applicability for the first part
but the the other one is all of the
businesses that
are still just barely alive at this
point
that were in fairly decent shape before
the pandemic
on that did not thrive during the
pandemic
that they had to close down for long
periods of time they didn't get revenue
we had one testimony about that
[Music]
and there are there were i think quite a
few of them
and a number of them did manage to get
ppp loans
more of them probably in the second wave
but in the first
wave which was three quarters of the
money
two thirds of the money on
the the loans went first to the
companies that had good banking
relationships
and those were more the ones that
that did pretty well during the pandemic
and don't really need
this assistance as a stimulus
so the question is whether
we would be able both
constitutionally and administratively to
to apply that and make sure
that we were mirroring the federal
intent
if not their law in terms of providing a
stimulus to the ones that
otherwise were going to die and that
right now
may be going to die if they have to pay
taxes when they didn't have any revenue
we can't change the rules that the
government
puts on these things but we need to
understand
what they are and how they differ from
one
group to the other and then
when they did get the stimulus did they
follow the rules we don't know that you
have to depend upon
the small business association or
whoever
referees that time
so we need a lot of discussion on this
anything else
any other questions or comments
then i guess we're all set until next
tuesday and what i would do is i'd come
in
thursday review those seven bills
and be ready
also review the two amendments
i i haven't heard of any other other oh
yeah
and hopefully we'll have the amendment
from representative spillsbury and
representatives chamber
all right thanks everybody i thought
today was
very interesting
have a great weekend